[Music]
Blakely has the most difficult job at
Cincinnati Zoo he has to play with
babies all the time he's never shown any
aggression or snapped if he gets upset
kind of like any mom would he just
leaves the room my name is dawn Strasser
and we're at the Cincinnati Zoo and
Botanical Gardens Blakely is a
five-year-old Australian Shepherd we got
him from a rescue and I use him in a
nursery as a nanny or a companion dog
this is about you and you're taking a
nap
blakeley's here for the main purpose of
teaching the babies the correct animal
cues as they grow up so when they are
introduced back to their own kind they
know what appropriate behavior is he
teaches them how to play how to interact
I can tell them no don't bite me but I'm
not an animal
and I don't give the same cues that he
can so we make a great team Blakely has
worked with cheetahs ocelots a-talkin
battered foxes a warthog Wallabies to
name a few he's working with four baby
cheetahs right now it's been a long
seven weeks for him with these little
cheetah cubs and he's I think tired
because he's on alert for 24 hours a day
if they start making too much noise
he'll come and get us like something's
not right something's not right he's
kind of like a second set of eyes for us
too a lot of times they still recognize
each other like Dale the talk and he
raised when they see each other
he'll they'll still run up in front and
grunt at him and he'll kind of jump up
on the wall and it's kinda like hey how
you doing
thank you yeah well I'd like to think I
have an office but I'm pretty sure it
says
[Music]
a lot of people see a cat up in a tree
they're just like oh yeah that thing
I'll get down here in a couple days
sweetie
how long you been in he's tricky but
what they don't realize is that
sometimes they don't I'm Sean serious
and I'm Tom Otto with canopy Cat Rescue
and we rescue cats that get stuck up in
trees cats get stuck in trees a lot
we've been rescuing since about 2008 I'm
getting you we've heard you more cat
rescues than anybody in the world we
range from about 375 to 400 rescues
every year okay there was a lot of
people that can't afford to pay your
normal arborist five six seven hundred
dollars to rescue a cat both Tom and I
really love cats
he's a total 3d ginger boy we'll come
out and rescue somebody's cat for free
canopy Cat Rescue this is Sean well I
think we'll be there in about 45 minutes
or so climbing trees is inherently risky
our average tree height is 100 feet
sometimes they're a lot taller we
started to sess out how the cats doing
as we're getting close and then
hopefully we can receive the rescue
we're gonna go on a staff how's that
sound
[Music]
the look that we get from the cat owners
face when we hand them their cat back is
just this overwhelming sense of relief
are you happy to have him back he's I
know we love doing this we're gonna do
it for as long as we can we don't really
consider ourselves heroes but we do like
to think of ourselves as just two guys
that are out there restoring the faith
in humanity
[Music]
I've been working with marine mammals
for almost 40 years
[Music]
when I started working with seals and
sea lions at job you know I was under
the impression that the trainer was
supposed to be in charge of the session
not the animals that's how most
aquariums do it but I don't think that
way anymore
[Music]
welcome to the New England Aquarium here
we have a selection of its million or so
annual visitors and here we have modeled
the turtle but we're really here to
introduce you to Kathy Streeter some
people call her the seal whisperer and
this is her marine mammal team here at
the aquarium we have six harbor seals
three sea lions and four northern fur
seals some of the animals were rescued
and some of them were born here
like most aquarium trainers Kathy's team
trains their animals with food for
example we taught a harbor seal to mimic
the sound of our voice he can utter how
are you but the team does something that
most aquariums don't they also interact
with their animals without food we call
it play so instead of us spending the
day dictating throughout what we want
them to do we are encouraging them to
show us what they would like us to do
it's totally up to them
tic-tac-toe right now we're teaching her
the strategy of just going to the
corners good where you gonna go Mirror
Mirror
string on a stick Luna loves to play
with string type things hit girl
ultimately I feel like it really
enriches the animals lives to be able to
participate with us in a whole different
type of interaction and one that is just
not based on food so we use that as the
reinforcement instead of fish and in
ceará session where she was doing the
initial stages of learning how to play
tic-tac-toe at some point she started to
vocalize so she offered to do
vocalizations instead of doing the
tic-tac-toe so we learned through clay
you know what are their preferences
[Music]
the standard comment we get from
trainers that visit from other aquariums
is that they're amazed that we can spend
time out on exhibit with our seals and
sea lions without having food to
interact with them you know everybody
would love to be able to do that I think
that play behavior for children for
adults and for animals is all extremely
valuable in the same regards it just
expands your brain
[Music]
first came the grasses they came in
thick then smaller shrubs with them the
insects returned then the trees and with
the trees the monkeys and elephants
here at size sanctuary we have over 300
acres a forest that we have replanted
and brought back to life
[Music]
my full name is Pamela Gayle Malhotra
and I am co-founder with my husband of
size sanctuary trust it had always been
our dream to have a private forest
sanctuary for wildlife where they would
be protected when we first came here
most of the lands that were sold to us
were abandoned lands abandoned rice
field Hassan and Hardiman fields as well
a lot of deforestation had taken place
and that took a lot a lot of care and
energy and time and years to bring it
back to really done well this year
people thought we were quite crazy but
that's okay a lot of people have thought
people that have done some amazing
things are crazy here in the sanctuary
it is a biodiversity hotspot I remember
walking through the forest you wouldn't
hear anything but the sound of your own
feet now the place is alive with sound
[Music]
one of our main sound makers are the
cicadas they have a tremendous decibel
range where they start again we keep
striving to do more and more but the
initial goal has been more than achieved
my hope for the next 10 years for this
forest is that it will continue to be
protected and expanded we both feel a
tremendous amount of joy when we walk
through the sanctuary I've never felt
this kind of joy and then anything else
that I've done in my life
[Music]